creo que llevo mucho hablándote acerca
del espacio no los de una matriz pero me
gustaría tocar en este vídeo otros
espacios vámonos a otros universos bueno
de hecho solamente quiero ver en este
vídeo el espacio columna de una matriz y
el espacio columna de una matriz es
bueno primero vamos a ver a nuestra
matriz nuestra matriz a que va a ser de
m por n hemos dicho varias veces que la
podemos escribir como un conjunto de
vectores de nuestros vectores b1 b2 así
y cada uno de ellos es un vector columna
de una columna de dos columna hasta bn
columna y como sé que tenemos en el
vector es porque tenemos una matriz de m
por ende tenemos n columnas y además
otra cosa que podemos saber es que cada
uno de estos vectores columna tiene m
componentes porque la matriz tiene m
filas como la matriz tiene m filas cada
uno de estos vectores columna tiene n
componentes o existe en r m y bueno ya
que tengo así a mi matriz amo y la estoy
viendo de esta manera entonces yo puedo
definir como el espacio columna de la
matriz
lo voy a denotar con una c mayúscula de
am se mayúscula de a es todas las
combinaciones lineales de estos vectores
y quien era todas las convenciones
lineales de estos vectores pues el
espacio vectorial generado por todos
estos vectores columna es decir b1 b2 b3
todos estos hasta pn por todos mis
vectores columna de a por eso se llama
el espacio columna de a y bueno no es
tan difícil ver que este espacio columna
de a es un sub espacio de hecho podemos
probarlo justo ahorita porque el cero
existe en cda el cero existencia de a
porque es una combinación lineal válida
para estos vectores columna de aps yo
pongo cero por b 10 por b 2 y así con
todas mis constantes 0 entonces voy a
obtener de resultado al vector 0 y por
lo tanto el 0 es un miembro del espacio
columna de a ahora bien me voy a tomar a
un vector a que existe en cda como a es
un vector que existe espacio columna de
a entonces lo podemos ver como una
combinación lineal de dos vectores
columna de a es decir
uno por uno más de dos porque 12 así
hasta almacene por ve en la pregunta es
el espacio columna de la matriz a es
cerrado bajo la multiplicación es decir
qué pasa si yo multiplico ese por el
vector a este vector existe también en
los espacios columnas de la matriz am
pues vamos a ver esto es exactamente lo
mismo que s posee 1 por b 1 más
s por 0 2 vuelve 2 más así hasta llegar
a ese porcentaje
lo cual también es una combinación
lineal de los vectores columna de a por
lo tanto ese día también debe de existir
en este espacio columna de a lo que
quiere decir que el espacio columna de a
es cerrado bajo la multiplicación ahora
ya vimos que el cero existe nada que es
una de las propiedades que es cerrado
bajo en la multiplicación y ahora hay
que ver si es cerrado bajo la suma así
que me tengo que tomar un vector que
esté en el espacio columna de amd y otro
vector que esté despacio columna d
lo voy a llamar bien el vector b también
está en el espacio columna de a además
del vector
hacer no se ve uno por b1 b2 b2 más
fácil esta bn por ver en el labial por
uwe y una vez que ya tengo al vector ahí
el vector ver lo que quiero saber es si
a más b existe en el espacio columna de
a esta es mi pregunta y bueno para esto
voy a tomarme am me voy a tomar ave y
los voy a sumar a ver qué me queda
quieres el vector a más del vector b
pues bueno si te das cuenta tenemos hace
1 multiplicando el vector b 1 y después
tenemos sumando al b1 multiplicando el
vector de 1 por lo tanto si sacamos como
factor común en welter b 1 me quedase
uno más de uno por b 1 y después lo
mismo con b2 c2 más b 2 por b 2 y
después lo mismo con b 3 y así hasta
llegar a b n cn que multiplica a su vez
al vector de n y si te das cuenta esto
es justo una combinación lineal de dos
vectores columna de la matriz por lo
tanto a más b existe en el espacio
columna de amd y con esto acabamos de
ver la tercera propiedad que necesitamos
para que sea un sub espacio el cero está
está cerrado bajo la multiplicación está
cerrado mejor la suma y entonces
concluir que el espacio columna de am es
un sub espacio un sub espacio válido muy
bien ahora vamos a seguir viendo cosas
que tengan que ver con el espacio
columna de a qué les parece si ya que
tengo aquí a mi matriz am ahora pienso
no sé en multiplicar la por algo así que
me voy a tomar a mi matriz y ya está la
voy a multiplicar por no esperar espera
déjame mejor ver este conjunto el
conjunto de la matriz am que multiplica
a un vector x a por x como lo que
teníamos la vez pasada pero recuerda que
para que esto esté bien definido lo que
estoy pensando es que x es un miembro de
erc n porque si la matriz asm por n
entonces el vector x tiene que ser de n
por 1 para que la multiplicación esté
bien definida entonces x existe en rn no
voy a tomar el conjunto de todas estas
posibilidades es decir voy a variar a
todos estos vectores existentes en rn a
todos los que tenga que en rn y me voy a
tomar la multiplicación de la matriz a
por este vector x que voy a obtener de
esto
fíjate bien lo que dices aquí la matriz
a va a multiplicar al vector x y x
existe en rn entonces que nos quedaría
de esto bueno pues aquí voy a poner a mi
vector x y mi vector x tiene como
componentes x 1 x 2 hasta llegar a x n y
esto ya habíamos visto varias veces al
yo tener la multiplicación de una matriz
por un vector lo podemos ver de la
siguiente manera la matriz a por el
vector x es exactamente lo mismo que x 1
que multiplica al primer vector columna
de amd más x 2 que multiplica al segundo
vector columna de an más y así nos
podemos seguir hasta llegar a x n que
multiplica al vector columna n de la
matriz am
es decir x n por b n y bueno pero qué
quiere decir todo esto que si yo me tomo
a un vector x en rn pues tendría una
combinación lineal de los vectores
columna de a ahora bien si pienso en
todos los vectores que existan en rn
entonces a que me estoy refiriendo a que
la multiplicación
a por el vector x lo puedo ver como el
siguiente conjunto y lo volver de la
siguiente manera esto mismo de aquí lo
voy a escribir así déjenme abrir otra
anotación de conjuntos porque esto lo
voy a ver como x1 por ver uno más x 2
por b 2 más y así hasta llegar a x en el
porve n pero lo que estoy diciendo es
que aquí tanto x1 como x2 como ustedes
como de hasta x n todos existen en los
números reales esto es justo la
definición de que el vector x exista en
rn lo único que estoy haciendo es
tomando me n componentes que cada una de
estas componentes existen en los nuevos
reales o tomando un vector en rn y bueno
si lo pienso de esta manera estoy viendo
que si yo lo que quiero es tomarme todas
las posibles combinaciones de estos
valores de x y x 1 x 2 x 3 x c n
entonces esto de aquí se va a convertir
en quien pues esto de aquí se va a
convertir en el espacio vectorial
generado por dos vectores columnas de la
matriz
es decir b1 b2 hasta bn el espacio
vectorial generado por estos vectores
columna porque
tomando todas las combinaciones lineales
posibles y esto es exactamente lo mismo
que lo que acabamos de definir que el
espacio columna de otra forma
interesante de ver lo mismo no porque
entonces podemos concluir que si
nosotros hablamos de este espacio
columna de la matriz am lo podemos ver
como todas las combinaciones lineales de
los vectores columna de an o en dado
caso como el espacio vectorial generado
por todos los vectores columna de la
matriz o en su dado caso como todos los
vectores x existentes en rn tales que se
cumpla la multiplicación de a por equis
o inclusive lo podemos ver de la
siguiente manera se tenga la matriz a x
el vector x y esto es igual no sé al
vector b 1 es decir me estoy tomando a
esta ecuación que tengo aquí esta
ecuación que tengo aquí es la que quiero
resolver sin embargo te digo que el
vector de uno no existe en el espacio
columna de amd no es un miembro del
espacio columna de an entonces tú puedes
construir rápidamente que esta ecuación
que tenemos aquí no tiene ninguna
solución y lo podemos decir con toda
certeza que esta ecuación
tenemos aquí no tiene ninguna solución
para x porque recuerda que por equis lo
habíamos visto como el espacio columna
de a todas las combinaciones lineales
que se forman de los vectores columna de
a existen en el espacio columna de a por
lo tanto si veo uno no existe en el
espacio columna de a entonces la
ecuación a x por b 1 no tienen ninguna
solución no tiene ninguna solución y de
la misma manera si yo me tomo la
ecuación a x igual a b 2 y te digo que
esta ecuación tiene al menos una
solución con quien tenga una solución
esta ecuación
en otras palabras estoy diciendo que ve
dos forzosamente debe de existir en el
espacio columna de a porque lo podemos
ver como una combinación lineal de los
vectores columna de amd entonces en este
caso concluimos que m2 debe de existir
en el espacio columna de a déjame
escribirlo aquí
aquí podemos concluir entonces que b 2
es un miembro del espacio columna de am
porque lo podemos ver con una
combinación lineal de los vectores
columna de a recuerda que si queremos
concluir este vídeo podemos decir que el
espacio columna de an es igual a todas
las combinaciones lineales de los
vectores columna de amd que a su vez es
igual al espacio generado por todos los
vectores columna de a que a su vez todo
esto es igual al conjunto de los
vectores x extender en el rn a todos los
vectores x existentes en rn con los
cuales podemos tomar la multiplicación
de a por x de cualquier manera creo que
te voy a dejar por aquí porque ya tienes
bastantes cosas abstractas que pensar
acabando este vídeo y en el siguiente
par de vídeos voy a tratar de juntar
todo lo que hemos visto es decir los
espacios columnas los espacios nulos y
todo lo demás para entender
perfectamente la multiplicación de una
matriz por un vector y esto visto desde
cualquier forma posible así que no te
pierdas nuestros siguientes vídeos